Donald Trump has reportedly suggested firing
impeachment inquiry witnesses who are working
at the white house effectively what would
end their tenure at the white house and send
them back to where they came from, so to speak.
Typically other departments, so as an example,
Lieutenant Colonel Alexander Veneman who testified
yesterday.
The way that this works is that different
employees from different departments are sort
of loaned to the white house for specific
jobs, and many of the people who have been
testifying over the last week, bill Taylor
for example, they're still working for the
government and sometimes for the Trump administration
in some way, even if not in the position they
held at the time of the Ukraine phone call,
which their testimony now focuses on.
On the one hand, Donald Trump has been talking
about let's fire these people.
On the other hand, he doesn't actually seem
to know that some continue to work for him
in some capacity.
And it's truly one of these, uh, uh, comedies
of errors that seem so common in the Trump
administration.
Trump lashed out yesterday, for example at
witness Jennifer Williams Williams works for
his vice president Mike Pence, saying she
should read the transcripts, very strange
attacks on someone that, uh, works for the
government and was employed directly by your
vice president.
And what's really important to understand
is that some of the witnesses appeared voluntarily,
but other witnesses appeared under subpoena
as they said.
Can you imagine firing someone for responding
to a subpoena?
In most administrations, it would be unthinkable.
In this administration, it seems almost to
be the default position to ignore legal constitutional
subpoenas.
So maybe they actually think people who respond
to subpoenas as required by the law are doing
something wrong and they deserve to be fired,
very different standards that are applied
under the current administration.
Um, another example is once again, yesterday's
witness, Lieutenant Colonel Alexander Veneman,
who confirmed a great portion of the narrative
of bribery and extortion that we've heard
so far.
Veneman is on the national security council
sort of on loan from the defense department.
The idea that's been floated is to fire Veneman
from the NSC, but what about firing him from
the defense department if he's truly what
the Trumpists are portraying him to be, which
is a dual loyal, which we'll get to, not credible,
whatever.
Why should he even be allowed to stay at the
defense department?
It doesn't make sense because none of this
makes sense.
Then his lawyer made it clear that Veneman
is on the national security council until
next summer.
Whether he will be allowed to stay, we don't
know.
Now a reasonable person would say, why would
they do this?
This makes them look more guilty.
This, this could count as witness intimidation
for future witnesses who consider appearing.
Why would they do this?
This is how Trump operates.
He doesn't realize or doesn't care that these
obstructive actions call more attention to
what he might've done.
Your mistake in questioning this strategy
is believing that there is a strategy, there
is no strategy.
These are just Trump's reactions, Trump's
behavior and his reflexive reactions and choices
make a lot more sense.
If you think of him not as a president but
more like a mob boss, then his choices become
far more clear and of course we'll see what
happens.
We'll see what repercussions there are for
the people who are participating in the impeachment
hearings, legal, impeachment hearings, individuals
who are showing up, including putting themselves
and their families at risk as we will talk
about soon, the idea that they are the problem
when they're exposing the problem is sickening,
but unfortunately it goes beyond just job
threats and that's what we need
to
talk
about next.